hello everyone welcome to cloud on air
live webinar from Google cloud we are
hosting cloud on our webinar every
Tuesday
my name is Aruna Anton pallium product
marketing manager for IOT and today we
will be talking about building
predictive maintenance solution using
machine learning with Google cloud you
can ask questions anytime on the
platform and we have Googlers stand on
standby to to answer them I'd start by
giving you a quick overview on Google
cloud platform and then go in-depth into
cloud IOT services for developers and
business leaders we will also talk about
existing IOT apps and services that
you're building on top of GCB as well as
all the rich capabilities that you can
take advantage of today we've also
planned a predictive maintenance live
demo so without wasting time let's jump
right in so what is Google cloud
platform or in Schad GCP GCP is a suite
of cloud computing services that runs on
the same infrastructure as our consumer
products such as Gmail Google search
YouTube and so on and so forth a smart
fact we have over seven products that
has more than 1 billion active users if
we look at it from an enterprise
customers point of view currently they
serve over 1 billion end-users each day
we are operating at a very high scale
and this is relative to other cloud
providers as you can tell we spent over
30 billion dollars in the last three
years on infrastructure making Google
cloud one of the largest investor in
computing infrastructures in the planet
and we are committed to offering a wide
range of IOT services and solutions both
for cloud and also for edge across
industries Google cloud has been named
as a leader in insight pass which is
platform as a service category we
believe this recognition reflects our
commitment to building a better cloud
the one that lets you innovate freely
build and deliver great products and
services faster to your end
Tomas and we cannot talk about cloud
services without addressing the back-end
infrastructure right do you know that we
own and operate one of the largest
backbone networks in the world
connecting our data centers with
hundreds of thousands of miles of fiber
optics cables our network can deliver
low latency very high throughput of
course with high security one of the
cost once the customers traffic is on
our network it's no longer transiting
the public Internet making it less
likely to be attacked intercepted or
manipulated according to one estimate
from Gartner it says about 10 billion of
so-called connected things will be news
in 2018 up 27 percent year-over-year
give or take and its projected to reach
about 20 billion dollars by 2020
these devices are generating tons of
data as you know right and Google has
been the forefront of addressing big
data challenges at scale for over 18
years now we are making these
technologies available for our end
customers our GCP customers so they can
accelerate the business transformation
it's that simple
our platform is now enabling customers
like slumber J and oil and gas Oden
technologies smart parking cog Knight to
cut cost and complexity while building
their IOT solutions we will dive deep
into some of the customer examples in a
moment on top of the best infrastructure
we have built a comprehensive set of
compute storage database data analytics
and mission learning services for our
customers now we now offer server lists
fully managed petabyte scale platform
which acts as the foundation for machine
learning and data analytics as you can
see on the screen we have end-to-end
services from capture all the way to
dashboarding for IOT use cases now you
can use scalable machine learning
services to move beyond simple data
analytics
and this is to attain actionable
insights even faster right and we have
developed reference architectures for
some of the common use like the use
cases like for example predictive
maintenance as a tracking this is with
complete documentation so you can
quickly go from pocs to implementation
in fairly a short timeframe now pulling
all these big tail data technologies
together and looking at four key pillars
right you can see that Google Cloud has
wide range of services to enable
business transformation this is a cross
enterprise right so services like cloud
IOT which is fully managed service
allows you to securely connect manage
and ingest data from millions of
globally dispersed devices right so the
devices could be located anywhere in the
globe would be able to connect to it
with a single endpoint in combination
with other services that Google Cloud
has to offer we can tell we can actually
tell the entire story right so you can
collect process analyze and visualize
IOT data in both real-time and also at
rest I'd give you a high-level overview
on some of these services before we dive
into the predictive maintenance
architecture so it'll give you some
context around what I'm talking about
the first one is the cloud pub/sub it's
publisher subscriber that you're very
much used to mqtt and it delivers the
service that we offer delivers low
latency and durable messaging it
connects services located anywhere in
the world and offers easy-to-use rest
JSON API is fairly simple bigquery is
another service that I wanted to point
out it's our answer to enterprise data
warehousing solution it is serverless
highly scalable low cost data
warehousing solution offered by Google
cloud it is designed to make all your
data analytics fast and effective
bigquery also
allows you to analyze what's happening
now by making your latest process asset
and business data immediately available
for analytics it's it's all real time so
the next one that I want to talk about
is the data flow the cloud data flow so
you can build fully managed data
pipelines and also do ETL
transformations using data flow we also
have a product called data proc which is
nothing but if fully managed Hadoop and
spark so you can also utilize that so if
you're coming from an Hadoop or spark
world would definitely recommend the
data proc or if you're building
something from scratch then dataflow is
the way to go last but not least
starting from right to left I'll start
with a cloud machine learning engine
first the cloud ml engine is also a
managed service that enables developers
and data scientists to build superior
mission learning models and to deploy
into production
we also offer auto mo so with the
limited mission learning expertise one
can train high quality models so you
don't have to start from scratch you can
take one of the pre-built models that's
available open source and Google has
committed to two open sourcing some of
these models already so I think we have
1,400 comets and github already on that
and this is this is something that we
can leverage and Google has something
called transfer learning technology so
you can apply that to build models we
also offer out-of-the-box machine
learning api s-- for example vision API
translation API video intelligence API
to to take advantage of Mission Lani so
now that you're familiar with Google
cloud platform and some of the
differentiated services that we offer we
can look at general architecture for an
IOT use case and how you can stitch
these different services to devil
together today
love a scalable application right so
okay over here device data is ingested
using IOT services the IOT core is
responsible for secure device management
and also device onboarding followed by
cloud pub/sub on the other hand the
service can handle incoming device data
at scale
and also the downstream services can
consume this data from pub/sub by
subscribing to a certain topic so one of
them as a cloud function I wanted to
spend a couple of minutes talking about
cloud function one it's no service to
provision manage or patch when it comes
to cloud functions it simply runs the
code and you pay for one Li the time the
code runs and it's fully managed so for
the even data that it receives from the
cloud pub/sub it can quickly perform a
data processing star task or a data or a
file processing task if it's a if it's a
file that's coming from the IOT core and
it can handle with the output back to a
IOT core or to other services this is
without spinning up virtual machines
it's a highly differentiated service
when compared to other providers and I
would encourage you to definitely try
that out and the dataflow once once it
gets the data from either cloud function
or pub/sub it can do ETL on the data and
it can either store it on a big table or
bigquery and for doing real-time this
for doing real-time analytics right
using you can use products like data lab
or even you can do machine learning on
the data that's on the bigquery right so
and like we talked about machine
learning we have multiple services if
you're starting from scratch then ml
engine is the way to go but if you if
you have a bunch of data and if you
take the existing model and kind of
train it to make it better then our mo
is the way to go finally if you're
looking to build an infinitive dashboard
then you can use data studio services to
do that we have built end-to-end
platform this is packed with rich
capabilities for all kinds of IOT use
cases as you can tell so the analytics
workload falls into four categories
descriptive diagnostic analytics
predictive analytics and prescriptive so
if you look at the descriptive and the
diagnostic analytics a lot of BI tools
and reporting tools can do that right
now for the predictive analytics and the
prescriptive analytics you need to do
some sort of emission learning that's
what we're going to talk about in the
coming slide so let's first talk about
the predictive maintenance which is a
version of a predictive analytics right
so as you very well know a very
well-loved understand right the
unpredictable downtime or unplanned
downtime it's commonly referred to this
is in production environment can cost
millions of dollars of losses and as
well as environmental damage and even
life hazards right so you know you can
make your manufacturing maintenance
department and operation teams more
proactive with predictive maintenance
but how would you accelerate building
high quality predictive maintenance
application for your enterprise and also
if you're an independent software vendor
which is is fees how will you develop
predictive maintenance solution for
different assets across industries these
are challenging problems right so well
we've developed an end-to-end platform
to address that challenge imagine if you
can build a solution from scratch which
automatically predicts when the
equipment needs maintenance that's just
amazing right and if you can do it in a
matter of weeks that's even better
so to build and deploy a machine
learning model you'll be following six
steps you start with collecting
information from from different
departments and also once you understand
the exact business problem you can
gather enough hypotheses as well right
so once you acquire all the data
including the device data telemetry data
data from manufacturers could be FMEA
and so on and so forth then you can
identify the best model there are
multiple models out there there are RN
ends cnn's right recurrent neural
network models that are convolution Airy
noodle neural networks model and there
are also specific model like that LSD ms
right so you can you can pick and choose
the model that's applicable for your use
case and then train that model using the
ml engine service that we have with the
data that you've already acquired the
data could be stored in cloud storage
the query you name it right so and once
you train that model then you can decide
on whether to deploy it in the cloud or
at the edge based on the use case so now
most of the predictive maintenance
solution that I have seen my experience
what it does is it takes few historic
patterns and uses one dimensional
pattern matching algorithms to predict
the failure of an asset which is not
really accurate and can be unreliable in
many instances right the solution that
we proposed is true predictive
maintenance both the end user and also
the independent software vendor can
develop ML models from scratch or taking
something and amplifying the accuracy
for some of those models this is for any
asset that they have and they can
incorporate this model into their own
Prem obligation or if they if they if
the app lies outside of the firewall in
many cases especially in in factories
then you can do callbacks to the server
to get new models
so if it's within the firewall then it
has the model has to be on a gateway
device or some sort of device right next
to the hasit but if there is an
opportunity to to put the model outside
of the firewall then you have a little
more freedom to to go back and forth new
callbacks on the to the cloud right so
in this case we used a specific kind of
RNN which stands for recurrent neural
network called LSD ms which is long
short-term memory that's what it stands
for
so that can that's the model that we
started with and then we've built a
predictive maintenance for this
particular application which I'm gonna
demo in few seconds and so once you
build a model then it's followed
evaluating the model right so use the
test data to test the model and the 8020
rule is 80% of the data that you've
gathered you can use to train the model
and 20% of the data can be used to test
the model so once the model is hyper
killed then it's ready for deployment
and prediction so let me provide you
with some context before I jump into the
demo so we're gonna take a real use case
and demonstrate machine learning as you
know a typical oil rig has about
thousands of sensors and control system
modules acquiring telemetry and process
data these are complex assets and these
assets are located in the middle of
nowhere and some of these assets they
don't have good connectivity to the
cloud so the models may have to reside
at the edge right so as a side note in
this particular demo we're going to
assume that the model is running right
next to the asset itself right so with
that in mind we can we can we can go and
see some of the some of the things that
we have done on the demo site
so again just to set the context this is
an example of complexities involved in
capturing and analyzing data from
connected devices so let's switch over
to the demo there you go so and again
this is a fictitious a an oil upstream
oil oil and gas manufacturer so here
they have a bunch of assets when you
double-click on one of those locations
as you can tell there's multiple
multiple sensors on these on these rigs
and you can drill into the specifics of
each of those so let me switch over to
the demo to show you exactly what I mean
by that there you go
so
go back to this one so when you click
one of these sensors it'll show you the
telemetry data coming from those
different sensors right so in this case
the operational dashboard reflects the
real-time machine data so this could be
tension the pressure temperature so the
viscosity of the of the oil and here's a
simple architecture of the predictive
maintenance application itself so the
data is gathered from these different
rigs and cloud IOT core publishes the
data to cloud pub/sub so once the
machine data has been gathered through a
gateway device it gets published to the
cloud pub/sub and Google IOT core once
it receives it of course with the time
stamp right it publishes to the to the
pubsub and from there the data flows to
the data flow as an event and we make
DNN regressor Cloud ml call from the
data flow and again the the data is
persisted on the bigquery in parallel
and also the data is sent in real-time
to the cloud ml engine right so the
predictive maintenance model is being
built in real time and then once it's
built then you can deploy it right and
start predicting right then and there so
once you deploy the model once you start
the prediction either you can write it
to a bigquery itself or otherwise you
can show it in real time on a
visualization engine so this is a very
simple architecture of predictive
maintenance
so this is a bunch of sensor data so we
are monitoring the device health with
incoming time series data here and we
can also easily and accurately determine
the predictive remaining life so if we
go back to the previous slide the red
bar that you see it shows exactly what's
the predicted cycle remaining in this
case zero which means that the acid s is
failing so you can actually get this in
real time so let's say that if a
predictive life's lifetime of an acid is
172 days then you know that within 172
days plus or minus what are their radius
the acid will fail so you can plan a
plan downtime rather than an unplanned
downtime which cost millions of millions
of dollars right so the predictive
accuracy is very important so some of
the applications that I talked about
previously the predictive applications
that you see in the market some of them
are not that I create which is which is
not the way it's supposed to be so when
you built a model using the ML engine
especially the RNN models that I was
talking about you can actually hyper
tune it to decrease the error rate so
when you see that green line pointing
down which means the the hyper tuning is
happening and we are increasing the
accuracy of the model so let's look at a
couple of customer examples and see how
they are taking advantage of GCP
services to improve their operational
efficiency so slumber j is one of them
and did as you know they're the leader
in providing oil and gas services they
use cloud IOT services like cloud IOT
core and other GCP services to capture
large amount of data and do analytics at
a petabyte scale the second one that I
wanted to talk about is the Odin
technology
they've built their Odin Factory
platform solution on top of GCP and
their technology empowers manufacturers
to eliminate waste and also increase
output Odin technologies they use the
hardened gateway devices battle-tested
once and what they do is they
retrofitted in existing industrial
plastic molding machines these are
legacy machines with little intelligence
right so they were able to collect and
process and also analyze to derive
insights from these data that's gathered
from that machine on a gateway device
and this is using the platform module
that they that they use from GCP
services right so they were able to
reduce the change over time about 33%
and getting the machines to an optimal
production faster is very very difficult
but with with the kind of insights that
they were that they were able to derive
they were able to do it quite faster and
this gave them the manufacturer an
additional thirty five hundred hours of
prediction every year this is about a
million dollars in in additional revenue
that they would have lost if if they
hadn't done something like this it's a
little more statistics on our stats on
Odin technologies so the call to action
is I encourage you to visit our website
Google there's a cloud sorry
cloud.google.com to sign up for free
trial today and also try out our ot
services like IOT core and so on and so
forth you can also learn more about the
IOT solutions so today I demoed the
predictive maintenance solution but we
also have asset tracking smart cities
and also we've done some work on the
remote monitoring side as well so
eventually
these demos will be posted on our
website and we are also planning to make
these codes available through github
fairly soon so you can learn a little
bit about use cases and also do a test
drive on our website and I would also
recommend you to to look at Android
things which is our Android things as
our operating system for IOT so you can
actually run predictive maintenance
model on top of Android things using a
tensorflow light inference on a gateway
device to do prediction right and this
is just one use case but you can do
quite quite number of things with that
and also the one takeaway is in addition
to the IOT core service we have
end-to-end services going from capturing
data to processing kind of cleansing the
data using ETL dataflow or data proc and
then either storing the data or doing
real-time analytics on that right so you
can do stream analytics you can do batch
analytics you can do a number of things
on top of that can also do machine
learning kind of going beyond simple
analytics and if you're interested in -
pudding also we have tools for that so
we have built an end-to-end platform for
all your IOT use cases so I definitely
recommend you to go try it out and we're
also partnering with well-known
companies like Intel microchip a number
of fronts the one I wanted to point out
is microchip we've done some work on the
security so this is hardware root of
trust is what we call it see there's a
proprietorship that goes on a
microcontroller which handles the
security side of things right so
with that
stay tuned for live Q&A we will be back
in less than a minute
you
hello welcome back everyone
so we have a list of questions let me go
through it one by one so how does google
help enterprises build predictive
maintenance solution how does an
enterprise go from building a POC pilot
to building a live production deployment
it's a good question so like I said
before the the best place to start is
once you understand understand the
business problem very well then you need
data right so from what from my
experience at least say I'm putting some
context to this question let's say let's
say it fits a an oil refinery right or
some sort of a manufacturing plant
either process or this Creek right does
matter most of those data is stored in
historian on-prem right could be a level
two the story in a level three historian
in some cases they do store it in a
private data center so but the data
doesn't leave the premises in those
instances what I would recommend is
first normalize the data what I mean by
normalizing is it could be number of
formats here that there is about 150
protocols out there right like Modbus
dnp3 BACnet you name it right so in the
branch batch processing world at least
I've seen OPC and OPC UA quite famous
protocols so normalizing it in one of
those formats and then taking the
normalized data and cleaning it up like
basically doing the ETL transformation
on the data so for example you don't
have to send every single bits and bytes
out of the historian you can normalize
doing like average temperature over a
particular window right so whatever you
can do to clean up the data and then you
can take the clean data and start doing
machine learning right so one way to
start machine learning is if you're not
familiar with some of these models there
is hundreds of thousands of models
already out there open source right
so of course Google has contributed to
many of those models already can go to
tensorflow or cafe or there are so many
other services out there where you can
take one of these models that's that can
do pretty good predictive maintenance
and start with that now with the data
and with a decent model you can start
building ml engine one of the Google
services can be used to actually train
that model make it better and then then
you have to make a decision whether to
include that model as part of an
application right or to have an app I
have a model separate and do some some
sort of a connection right so if you
have an asset manager or an asset
predictive maintenance if you're running
some sort of an application like that
then I would definitely recommend that
model stays separate from your
application because you may have the
assets so you can build models for
individual assets could be turbines
could be steam engine or whatever
whatever whatnot right so that's the
best place to start and we have
end-to-end services to do that right now
on Google cloud as a matter of fact
there's multiple webinar that's already
been done on YouTube that he can go take
a look at to start this work so good
luck with that second question is what
kind of protocols does IOT core supports
so right now we support MQTT and HTTP
but in the future we may support
protocols like a.m. QT and ku apps so
any device and device that can
communicate mq TD or HTTP can connect to
IOT core and IOT core is a universal
endpoint so what works doesn't matter
where your devices are could be anywhere
in the world as long as you can you can
talk those protocol you can communicate
to cloud IOT core so can you list some
of the customers or platforms yes so in
my presentation I've listed some
examples like slumber J is one Oden
technologies on top of that we have fog
horn which is our partner they have
their die okie platform on they've built
that IOT platform on top of GCP as well
and we also have ila they've also
recently started supporting our or
integrating their solution with IOT core
service so we're seeing a lot of the IOT
platform providers supporting that so
what if I don't have any training data
can I gather it in real time yes so of
course any time we talk about machine
learning clean data and a lot of data is
good right it's it's always the case but
we do have certain pre-built api's like
for example in many of the industrial
use cases I've seen the the visual API
right that comes in handy so it's
already pre-built model so you can start
with maybe hundreds and thousands of
images let's say that if you don't have
thousands you can start with hundred
hundred images and you can still train
that model for a certain application you
can do that same thing using let's say
that if you if you have some sort of a
terminal if you want to do some sort of
a thermal imaging on something and
predict the result then you can use our
video intelligence for it of course we
also have an NLP which is not a natural
language processing API again if you
wanted to get in read a bunch of data
points could be a sentence sentence or
it could be a Twitter feed or whatnot
and if you wanted to derive emotions
from that you can certainly do that so
for that you don't need a ton of data
and you can use real time data that's
coming in to to do machine learning on
that right
so and we also have another service
called Auto ml so if you're not sure
what model to pick don't have high
quality data then auto auto melissa is
another way to go so with the limited
data it can actually recommend you a
pretty good model where the accuracy is
the north of 70% at least in in most use
cases and then you can kind of hyper
tune from there right the next one is
does google cloud offer out-of-the-box
models for image recognition and
classification yes so the visual API
that I was talking about can be used for
image classification and image
recognition and a lot of the industrial
use cases I've seen they have a bunch of
labels and they want it to be able to
name those labels what those are right
so in those cases again you can use the
visual API to to do that and of course
there's a lot of other use cases where a
pre-built model will come in handy in
those instances you can refer to one of
the pre-built models that we are already
marketing or you can actually find
something from the open-source community
as well right and use the ml engine or
REM all to two to build and train the
model right so where can I go to try out
the IOT services it's a good question so
cloud.google.com / IOT - core that's one
of the IOT services that we have and you
can actually go to cloud google.com to
do a free trial so on the top right hand
corner you would see a launch button
once you launch it you will ask you for
your Google accounts if you don't have
one you can create one there and then
you can take advantage of some of the
cloud services so the next question is
lived pricing so we do offer the first
250 Mb free per month for the IOT core
service
and we have a very competitive pricing
model and a simple pricing model for you
to to understand the next one is can I
do real-time analytics on telemetry data
received from equipment yes so we can do
both real-time which is streaming
analytics and also batch analytics the
way we differentiate us right now
to do those different things you may
have to write additional line of codes
or you may have to use different tools
altogether right so in in in Google
clouds case we have a product called
data flow right which is fully managed
service where you can do eat a lance
firm ation and also do analytics using
bigquery in real time and you don't have
to write additional line of codes for
real-time and streaming and sorry
streaming analytics and batch analytics
and it's fairly easy to orchestrate a
ETL pipeline and go from there
so again there's ton of documentation
resources out there both in video format
and also and documentation format for
you to go look at so I would highly
recommend looking at some of the next
videos or the the Google i/o videos that
we have done on that the last question
is I don't know Python can I do ml in
any other language yes so we do support
multi a multiple languages we do support
are we support of course Python and C++
in certain areas so there's there are
multiple ways that we can you can
program Shin learning models and
I don't know exactly how many languages
we support but this is something that
you can refer to our ml Engine website
to gather the details again the
documentation is pretty good there so
with that thank you for your time and
the next session that we have is on AI
so I highly recommend that stick around
to watch that
you